and there can you see more polymorph  going towards them all now and not now  about two minutes ago it was a lot of  and worst traffic jams are not cause the  highway and how big an area have the  police cleared sorry how big an area  have the police cleared well not easy to  tear maybe 500 meters from that point  under more and you seeing quite a lot of  people still around the area or people  trying to get further away so it seems  like they're going away some of them  going in this area but the most of them  are leaving the arena but just for the  direction of the devil can't get it okay  Maximilian thank you very much for your  time and stay safe and and thank you for  your comments on the situation in Munich